[Music]
ai is on the verge of revolutionizing
health care without even looking at you
let alone laying a hand on you I can
diagnose and treat any number of medical
conditions with far greater speed and
accuracy than even house on his best day
one infamous GSB alum even went so far
as to say that you want the next
generation of doctors go look in the
computer science department algorithms
will replace stethoscopes and you know
what even if that meant that I was out
of a job I wouldn't even care because
all I really care about is doing what's
best for you and when the price of human
error is just so great I can totally
understand that it might be time to
start dispensing with the human imagine
that you've been awake for 52 hours but
you're not at Burning Man you're just
getting home from work
and you've only just nodded off to sleep
before the phone rings again and you
need to be on your game straight away
because it's Eric a first-year doctor
working alone in rural Australia and
he's ringing you he says because he's
very worried about a patient he's got in
fact he thinks he needs urgent surgery
because the scan it looks kind of funny
I roll my eyes we can't spend a hundred
thousand dollars and deploy a skilled
airlift retrieval team for a patient
with a diagnosis of funny I tell Eric
and I ask him if he can send me a
snapshot of the CT scan which he does
and thankfully it looks entirely
unremarkable I ring him back and perhaps
just because I'm so exhausted I ignore
the quiver of uncertainty in his voice
and I just say to him with all the
confidence in the world there's nothing
wrong with the scan mate don't send him
over by air emergently tonight but send
him over by Road and I'll see him
sometime in the morning
and I fall asleep before I even hang up
the next morning refreshed after my four
and a half hours I walk into work and I
arrive at about the same time as the
patient I take the scan and I loaded up
into the computer and what I see is
remarkable not only is his a ordered
acepted which means that the wall has
split into two but he's actually leaking
blood from it this man needs urgent
surgery but he needed it hours ago while
I was sleeping I ran over to him to try
and undo my mistake in fact I want to
take a scalpel out there and there and
get going but I can't his name's Jack
he's got a shiny bald head flanked by
unruly gray curls he's got this
fantastic moustache sitting on top of a
very broad toothless smile and somehow
he's managing to eat peanut M&Ms which
are perched on his potbelly and he's
meant to be fasting but I can't blame
him because they're my favorite too any
and he offers me one we shake hands and
we look each other in the eye and and he
says to me get a David boy am I glad to
see you Eric told me that you were the
man and uh boy boy I'm feeling sheepish
and I look him back in the eye and I say
hardly the man jack in fact I think I
made a bit of an error but those were
the last words that Jack heard because
and it was the funniest sensation ever
but his hand went limp in mine and he
tried to say something but couldn't and
he just let off a little bit of a groan
and behind me on the screen you see his
blood pressure go from 70 to 30 to zero
and people run from everywhere and pound
on his chest but I know it's futile
because his a order is ruptured and
there's no getting him back from that
and it's all because of my era the could
haves and the should'ves of this scene
still keep me up late at night but it
was only because of Jack that this year
a colleague of mine at Stanford and I
built a deep learning algorithm that
could automatically diagnose this exact
emergency and recommend a treatment plan
Jack would have been flown to hospital I
would have been woken up but he would
have had his life saved and this is just
one example of why when people say AI in
health care it's just way more than a
buzz term to me but while I'm up late at
night thinking about Jack I also can't
help but wonder what does this mean for
the future of medicine would it really
be safest if we just distill all of our
patients you guys down to processes of
pattern recognition and image detection
and if so when you or your loved ones
are at your sickest and most vulnerable
who do you want by your side
man or machine well only a few years
before Jack I was sitting on the other
side of the fence in the waiting room
with the person I loved most
my sister Jackie waiting for a diagnosis
and waiting for a treatment plan and I
do wonder how that day might have gone
were we to meet a machine say an AI
oncologist because any good AI
oncologist would need data inputs and
these were Jackie's age 16 symptoms
intermittent pelvic pain loss of weight
and bloating findings at operation a
large malignant mass now if medicine is
just about making the right diagnosis
and giving the right treatment this
would be a five minute consultation and
I could write that code today your data
outputs would be diagnosis a rare
malignant tumor treatment plan twelve
months of chemotherapy and radiotherapy
prognosis uncertain but surely even a
half-assed AI oncologist would want to
know if we had any questions because
that day Jackie had plenty a eye
oncologist am I going to lose my hair
and how am I going to look well you will
easy here you'll look bald a eye
oncologist I love children I'm 16 now am
I going to be able to have children
after all this chemotherapy and
radiotherapy the statistics would
suggest unlikely but I'm I'm not an AI
gynecologist
ái oncologist am i going to die and as
the tears streamed down our faces surely
any half-decent AI oncologist would be
able to use image detection to see those
tears and robotic ly dispense us with a
tissue but is this really the kind of
care that we want because at that moment
what these two petrified kids needed was
so much more than a diagnosis and
treatment plan in fact that was the easy
bit we didn't need some watson or
advanced clinical decision support
software what we needed and what we got
thankfully was a very human person who
would stand up walk over to the other
side of the desk put his arms around us
and say that despite what the algorithm
said everything was going to be okay
that he and not some fandangled machine
would be with us every step of the way
yes
ai is going to do amazing things and
it's going to help all of us in this
room it's going to save lives it's going
to slash medical error and it's going to
improve access to care but being a great
doctor is about so much more than making
the right diagnosis it requires a
delicacy a touch and a judgement that
even the best technologists will never
be able to replicate so as we build
amazing machines to make you guys safer
it will not be the computer scientists
who become the great doctors of the
future it will be humans like Jackie who
overcame the algorithms and just
graduated medical school last year
who
the humans like Jackie who possess the
skills that are just way too difficult
to code for
[Applause]
[Music]